après l'association Rêve tout à l'heure
qui réalise les soins des enfants
malades nous reparlons solidarité dans
cette édition du 7 8 du 19 mars avec le
rotar acte club de Versailles bonsoir à
Linda Moutier vous êtes la responsable
communication attachée du club et puis
Thibault Mathieu bonsoir vous en êtes le
président le rottaracte club ce sont ces
jeunes de 18 à 30 ans qui sont impliqués
qui développent des projets ensemble
avant de parler justement des différents
projets et particulièrement de ces
potagers solidaires que vous avez mis en
place c'est votre première grande
opération opération d'envergure tout
simplement qui sont ces jeunes qui
participent au club alors merci de
faveur de votre invitation pardon alors
le club de Versailles retrac club de
Versailles c'est ce sont des jeunes de
18 à 30 ans
issus de la des Yvelines donc Versailles
de Saint-Quentin de Jouy-en-Josas Vélizy
jusqu'à Mantes-la-Jolie tout le monde
peut en faire partie tout le monde peut
enfin partir vous avez 18 ans jusqu'à
jeudi 30 ans donc peut-être que vous
même peut-être
mais dis-moi en tout cas tout le monde
peut faire partie absolument ce sont à
la fois des étudiants des jeunes actifs
et des jeunes en recherche ce que
j'appelle recherche c'est à la fois des
jeunes en recherche d'emploi ou bien en
recherche de formation parce que tout le
monde n'a pas la chance de trouver la
bonne formation au bon moment comment se
passe la vision alors l'adhésion alors
l'occurrence c'est une adhésion donc oui
qui est payante mais à proportion gardée
on a on tourne autour d'une trentaine
d'euros par an et par membre donc ce qui
aurait relativement raisonnable et
ensuite donc c'est un système évidemment
de parrainage donc nous nous souhaitons
avoir uniquement des jeunes motivés car
c'est très important d'être motivé quand
nous faisons les actions que nous que
nous voulons mettre en place et que nous
avons commencé déjà à mettre en place
donc il faut avoir des gens motivé et
des gens qui veulent la finance
s'impliquer alors le mode d'ordre c'est
l'amitié par le service c'est à dire
l'amitié par le service c'est aider un
maximum de personnes à travers des des
petits services notamment par exemple
les potagers solidaires c'est c'est
mettre en place des bacs avec une
multitude de légumes différents de
fruits et légumes différents et de
donner la possibilité à un maximum de
personnes des Yvelines donc de
Versailles et des alentours de pouvoir
accéder à tous ces légumes gratuitement
et donc voilà donc c'est de l'amitié par
le service alors justement parlons de ce
projet que vous avez commencé à évoquer
c'est potagers solidaires ça va ça va
fonctionner comment vraiment
concrètement alors tout d'abord il
faudra rappeler le contexte les potagers
solidaires sont à la base un projet qui
s'appelle
incredible donc incroyable comestible
qui a commencé il y a cinq ans à ton
Morden par negrine en Angleterre et donc
c'est un concept que nous allons
reprendre ici en France et notamment un
fort Fiori dans les Yvelines puisque les
Yvelines grâce au club de Versailles va
devenir un département pilote donc le
concept est très simple même devant
votre studio je suis sûr qu'on peut
ouvrir exactement l'idée est simple on
va en fait mettre sur la voie publique
des bacs des bacs en bois de 2 mètres
sur deux environ 1 m de hauteur et dans
ces bacs qui seront remplies de terre
nous allons mettre des semences de
légumes des semences de légumes modernes
et des semences de légumes anciens parce
qu'on trouve que c'est aussi notre
petite notre petit apport yvelinois pour
découvrir
en l'occurrence où il nous avons la
chance d'avoir le Potager du Roi et le
château et bien profitons de cette
avantage pour mettre en lumière des
légumes qu'on ne vend plus l'habitude de
manger et donc les légumes vont pousser
et tout le monde je dis bien tout le
monde de façon gratuite pourra se servir
donc c'est très important on passe dans
la rue si on veut servir on se sert
exactement ça peut être le jogger qui
passe un dimanche après sa course s'il a
besoin d'une tomate hyper manger une ça
peut être la grand-mère qui est en bas
de chez elle va n'a plus de quoi faire
un potage et il lui manque un poireau ou
une tomate et bien ou bien ne serait je
ne sais pas moi une pomme de terre etc
elle peut descendre ça peut être
également les chômeurs ça peut être
également les gens qui sont sans
domicile fixe mais également des jeunes
ça peut être des étudiants on oublie
qu'il y a trop d'étudiants qui vivent en
mangeant trop de pâtes la semaine ça
peut être également des gens tout
simplement qui veulent faire partager ou
faire découvrir
l'art de la culture l'art de mettre les
mains dans la terre soit à leurs enfants
ou bien à leurs petits-enfants à leurs
voisins etc etc c'est à la fois très
beau projet mais on imagine aussi qu'il
y a des contraintes parce que ça se base
aussi sur le respect de chacun parce
qu'il faut que tout le monde se
retiennent un petit peu n'abuse pas en
tout cas de ce qui sera mis à
disposition et puis il faut aussi le
surveiller il faut planter il faut
l'entretenir qui va s'en occuper comment
fonctionne ce projet alors c'est
pourquoi la communication et la
pédagogie auprès de la population est
essentielle nous avons des partenariats
notamment avec la ville de Versailles la
ville de Vélizy la ville de
Jouy-en-Josas est bientôt la ville de
Mantes-la-Jolie dans lequel nous sommes
en train de préparer cela la préparation
de ces bacs c'est le retard club de
Versailles qui en est le coordinateur
principal donc il y a même je quelqu'un
qui nous a contacté de Saint-Cyr parce
qu'il aimerait également me développer
ça à Saint-Cyr donc on va en mettre
également à Saint-Cyr l'école donc ces
bacs là vont être à la fois garder par
les habitants mais également par la
ville parce que par exemple au niveau
des grandes vacances je parle du mois
d'août quand tout le monde est en
vacances et bien il est rare de les de
laisser un jardin ou un potager en bonne
en bon état donc là oui ce sont les
services de la municipalité de chaque
municipalité qui va venir donner un coup
de jet d'eau essayer de ramasser
quelques feuilles ou etc enfin d'essayer
de l'entretenir sur ces mois de vacances
sur le parle de juillet et août
principalement et c'est un projet qui
intéresse même à l'étranger espagnol qui
est venu faire un reportage sur vous
France Inter s'y est intéressé également
est-ce que vous avez d'autres projets
qui qui sont prévus de même envergure ou
moindre envergure travailler sur quel
projet alors là on voit les photos
c'était à France Inter effectivement et
puis la télé espagnole qui s'était
intéressée
donc oui mais c'est important parce que
c'est de la solidarité on est jeune on
est aussi conscient de la situation
actuelle on est aussi conscient que si
on n'a pas un minimum solidaire et bien
rien ne fait enfin on ne peut pas faire
les choses seul et on a la chance
d'avoir un toit sur la tête d'avoir deux
jambes de bras et un cerveau qui
fonctionne pas à peu près donc je pense
que c'est la meilleure le meilleur
remerciement qu'on puisse faire c'est
s'engager et se faire adhérer les gens à
cela et d'autres idées de projet alors
oui alors nous avons un on va
s'intéresser à des projets par rapport à
l'enfance d'accord surtout aux enfants
qui ne peuvent non pas la chance dans
les Yvelines de partir en vacances on va
s'intéresser à l'eau l'eau potable l'eau
potable est un engagement majeur et
c'est un problème qui va devenir majeur
et on veut également s'intéresser aux
professionnels aux formations et donc là
c'est dans ce cadre là que nous allons
recevoir des professionnels connus et
reconnus dans leur domaine pour pouvoir
venir nous informer informer nos jeunes
des principales débouchés de leur métier
alors vous ne manquez pas d'idée mais si
jamais si jamais vous manquez d'idées en
tout cas nous sommes allés poser cette
question aujourd'hui dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin quelles actions
aimeriez-vous mener quelles actions
justement solidaires
que des skis pour savoir un petit peu
les projets qui peut y avoir sur la
ville nouvelle un investissement comme
ça sur les projets les associations
sportives pour aider les jeunes déjà
peut-être à mieux s'intégrer des
personnes qui sont dans qui sont âgées
qui sont qu'on a besoin d'animer qu'on a
besoin de
d'épauler de divertir de en vue des
enfants en difficulté scolaire je ferais
bien de l'aide aux devoirs tout ce qui
est les sens logique et tout ce qui est
la tout ce qui est les gens qui n'ont
pas qui n'ont pas de quoi manger pour
les enfants par exemple en Afrique
c'est vrai que je voyage beaucoup en
Afrique donc solidarité pour les enfants
qui sont la misère en Afrique quelques
idées de projet voilà vous avez été
attentifs vous avez même pris des notes
ce soir ce sera aussi la naissance
véritablement du rotaracte club il y a
la charte qui sera présenté à Versailles
de France à 20h et sa symbolise vraiment
la naissance de notre club
donc voilà on sera donc parrainé par le
retard club de Versailles et donc il y
aura qui sera présent le gouverneur du
district des Yvelines qui sera donc
présent pour nous remettre cette charte
aujourd'hui vous êtes combien à faire
partie du club du retard club de
Versailles on est une cinquantaine mais
on espère atteindre la santé assez
rapidement
Club de France si je me trompe pas c'est
ça oui le plus grand que la brique merci
d'être venu me présenter vos projets de
Versailles qui développe donc ces
opérations de solidarité dont c'est
potager solidaires que vous verrez
peut-être bah fleurir ici et là à
travers le département voici à présent
le rappel des titres quelques-uns des
sujets que nous avons abordés ce soir
depuis le début de cette heure où nous
sommes ensemble la semaine nationale de
l'artisanat dans les Yvelines plusieurs
manifestations au programme jusqu'au 22
mars il y a notamment ce breakdaige qui
s'est déroulé ce midi pour faire se
rencontrer des dirigeants nouvellement
installés et puis il y aura des portes
ouvertes dans les CFA ce weekend des
voyageurs insatisfaits et qui le font
savoir une pétition circulant ce moment
sur la ligne de car 50 ans on Yvelines
Poissy pour réclamer notamment de
meilleures fréquences plus de 100
signatures recueillies en l'espace d'une
semaine à la commémoration du 19 mars
avant la date officielle de célébration
de la fin du cessez-le-feu en Algérie
dont se réjouissait ce matin les
associations d'anciens combattants
notamment à la verrière vous le voyez
sur ces images et puis les ondes
électromagnétiques et c'est danger
potentiels Stéphane Loriot chargé
d'animation au sein du parc naturel de
la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse il est
hypersensible aux ondes et nous a
raconté son quotidien et vous pourrez
bien sûr revoir ce reportage son
portrait sur notre site internet c'est
la fin du 7 8 demain 18h en direct je
vous retrouverai avec une large base
culture consacrée à la musique musique
pour les plus jeunes et puis également
du jazz avec un festival en Vallée de
Chevreuse et puis bien sûr nous ferons
le point sur toute l'actualité locale
excellente soirée à demain